hello and this is me playing black lions
Guinea oh there's no name right nope
okay many switch back to some Queens
gambit accepted Oh surprising how many
people play that line was 93 it's it's
totally out of fashion but still it's
pretty often played in blitz chess
surprising it's completely out of
fashion with some reason but turn and
some are in those quick term control
games people are still playing yeah it's
a pretty strange kind of position here
the night on 85 but it's supposed to be
pretty okay for black keeping that pawn
on c4 e6 very weird stuff you 65 g5 set
that a line looks very weird maybe just
play a normal move here first and then
think about it yeah 6g 65 g5 some very
weird form of the of the pot Vinick but
when exam is love you 5 g five that
should be ok for me I guess it's very
weird as I said very strange with the
night only five but ok it keeps the pole
and it sometimes can jump favorably to
be three actually could have done that
know that I think of it a technically
form yeah this is some a possible
problem
okay so let's try to grab material so I
guess route p1 look a to that rook will
never move again probably I see out for
some kind of wacky exchange sacrifice
here it is the wacky exchange sacrifice
okay so Queen d4 I guess just grab that
big pawn rook v3 rooty one and don't
believe in that shouldn't be enough
compensation I get to take a three and
castle long this is just a huge material
advantage and objectively absolutely
never enough take a three second bhakti
one
maybe still should be possible yeah of
course root do you want women to us is
possible this is just a bluff bluff or
whatever cannot pronounce that word it
seems but so what now d 8
and I guess got the six covered check
white resides yeah it's just really just
look down that yeah the thing is that 93
is not very popular because of 86 and b5
whiter normally goes efore here and a 4s
this is not good simply 96 95 is
supposed to be better for black already
in turn the question is however how to
play here I mean that looked logical but
i'm not sure if it is the main line or
whatever I already have ideas here with
that capture on every but maybe maybe
around here I could have done there now
engine gives you five and with unclear I
mean I mean zero but it's very high
clear Heath what I'm trying to save
that's a funny line and e6 now I don't
like it 25 and this I don't think it
works okay the engine gives this which
is looking dangerous
stock which just gives equal which is
funny of course in a super-sharp
position like that it wants to play five
based on the check and check on this
idea and I'm sorry and maybe just here
yeah I'm two pawns up but why it has
pretty strong playing so let's give
anything can happen here Queenie too
well it's very strange and this is
probably not working I don't believe it
now hip like it's winning it's just not
just not playable at all check oh oh my
god in this position we have a have a
nice little tactical puzzle for you
after update why to play and win ok I'm
going to show it now check BAM check
check check mate bow wow I dodged a
pretty pretty substantial bullet down
Queenie 6 was check mate in three moves
and here white is lost Wow now Queenie 6
wasn't on my radar at all I wasn't I
wasn't thinking in terms of mates here I
thought that ok although this piece is
not doing much is this night might come
here which is covered quite
film Wow amazing poo thanks for watching
guys that was very lucky